yeah I mean look at the end of the day
humans are affected by other humans what
I'm just always trying to think about is
like can I say one sentence a different
way that makes people realize like
nothing good comes of not doing
something you want to do because you're
worried about what somebody's gonna say
it just doesn't work that way you know
yeah and I think that's you know I don't
for you I don't think there's one piece
of content I think was Final just like
for me it's just like [__] it like you
know it's been long enough and I
actually you know if I have to say it
was one thing it's it's you know when I
ask myself you know when you're 80 when
you're 90 are you gonna like are you
gonna wish you did it or not right and
are you gonna whether it's your mom your
dad your brother a former relationship
your best friend or or just anybody do
you think at 80 or 90 you're going to be
happy that you didn't do something
because of their opinion versus not
doing something that was in your stomach
yeah and you know
like right now sorry what am I trying to
say good because what's good about
having time yeah yeah
speaking of that I I was surprised I
even got like I was telling Sid about
this you know he's like why'd you get
this one I was like honestly like
there's a couple reasons you know I want
to help see behind the scenes the brand
stuff but it was a good deal like I
agree like it wasn't cheap but I said I
can't remember exact price but like 90
minutes plus the five days I was
surprised it even got so I wasn't
planning to get this one I get it you
know I agree like like I'm very
comfortable with not to mention the V
content like like the like I'm really
excited about this project long term and
like there were some really interesting
Arbitrage
a lot of times I build things for
younger me
I almost think a lot of times garyvee is
the person I wish existed for me when I
was in high in junior high high school
it would have really helped me like I
had a lot of things that took longer
than they could have had I grew up in
this era and had a resource like this
and then like this for example oh my God
if this existed when I first started
Vayner
and I could have had a five-day thing
and gotten access to whomever she or he
was that I admired is doing something
similar that would have been a
tremendous return on my mommy no
for sure um but yeah going back to while
standing so you know I'm doing work
three uh just content just that you know
I love the web 3 space I don't know
exactly
you know I do see me you know coming up
with a service or a product one day but
I don't know what which direction you
know D5 gaming stuff something stuff
like that but I think this is a good way
just to expose myself to all of it right
you know I just actually the podcast
today will be my second episode only for
first guests that I just did the intro
episode last week you know just letting
you know let people know that's awesome
so uh you know it's a big it's a big
shift for me but it's it's something
yeah I want to meet your 90 I'll look
back and I have wanted to be able to say
I tried it because while I think that
I'm going to enjoy it once I you know
I'm getting more and more comfortable
the truth is you know unless you're
gonna get something a shot maybe you
know I was talking to Dustin saying he
tried the vlogging thing it wasn't for
him yeah right but he didn't know until
he tried it right yeah that's exactly
right you can't you don't know that your
favorite food is a baked potato until
you actually eat it you know and people
eliminate oysters and caviar and foie
gras and all these you know uni and all
these you know foods that I love that
you know people don't they just like the
amount of people that have told me at
dinner because I order oysters a lot I'm
like would you like some and they're
like no I don't like oysters and I'm
like have you ever had one I would say
three out of four have never had it I
was just gonna say I didn't like it
yeah there's a lot of good oysters from
Canada by the way
um you know it's really real it's the
thought of I understand like like you
know I've had some like pretty weird
conversations of why people don't like
oysters they're like the consistency the
look it all makes sense but it all goes
down to the same thing which is like are
you fearful
to try something or are you Fearless you
know
I just really admire lack of fear I was
watching uh some kids play basketball
yesterday
and there's one kid two teams were a big
mismatch but this one kid like just
wasn't scared and I admire that
I really it's funny that I caught my
attention while I was watching something
like it's just
awesome I'm pumped that you're at such a
young age that you're starting to like
really chip away at it yeah you know I
can look back and say like oh no because
I want to do this for like you know 28
now I got last six years really you know
but I was never saying I used to be a
nurse and stuff like that and I'm
working at other projects and stuff for
other people
but I said you know I could look back
and say like you know I've wasted time
or say you know for All This Time ahead
of me right so it's such a little piece
I mean I you know when you're 28 six
years is a ton
[__] 20 you know it's a ton it's over
20 percent so it feels like a ton just
like I tell a lot of people like so
obviously you know this because you know
my content I talk so much about patience
and everyone loves to make fun of me
like my favorite comments by far on
social media is like get review rolls up
on a 90 year old and says how old are
you they say 90 and he says you got and
I laugh but like you know it's funny I
get it when you're 12.
a year seems like an eternity
you're like next year right when you're
47 years are flying I talk you know and
it's just how the human brain works so
of course when you're 28 six years like
whoa it's 20 of your [__] time like
you know like you felt it but it's
nothing
it's nothing and like it's great
especially when you know a lot of people
don't get to this place until 40 50 60.
to be that's why I'm so passionate about
making the content I make if I can get
13 to 33 year olds to understand they
haven't started and regardless of
anything that's happened there's
actually a fresh restart and you can
fully like you could be miserable and
have like and die at 92 with like a
profoundly happy life because 60 years
more in front of you is just 60 years
more in front of you
I just really wish people believed it
and so like what now like what do you
like when you go back to analyzing
things like in dream state hypothesis
when you were like okay I'm gonna be
here
for you know a week you know kind of
like did you go into like I hope I leave
with
like a secret weapon to make your
content go viral yeah a relationship
with Gary that you can relate like you
know what I mean like I'm curious you
know of course right of course another
relationship with you hopefully you know
we also I don't know if you know on the
the garage sale yes I'm looking forward
to that so that's gonna be just a real
like yeah almost you your point like you
can't spend that much as long as I'm not
a piece of [__] you can't spend that
much time with a human and not have
something you know
but but no and then like just you know
little connections like that's something
I've been terrible at you know a lot
I've kind of you talk about fear like
I've really just found my comfort zone
last five six years and just not really
explored out a bit that means like you
know I wasn't I haven't been networking
and stuff like that
um kind of just been like a Hermit yeah
right but on all well first of all kovid
was a big chunk so that like added to
the convenience of being a Hermit yeah
that was like that was like two three
two and a half a year you know but like
like I I think about that a lot like all
of us even you know I am the most
extroverted most Network like most rely
on other humans for my energy and like
I'm like out of practice a little bit
like like I'm like I don't want to be
out from eight to midnight doing like
things like I'm like like it's it's you
have to like almost restart in some ways
but no it's good friendships you know
real like intimate relationships dating
business Network like all humans get so
much value out of other humans I think a
lot about forced
forced perspective
like this is why I'm actually really
trying to get like
like it shouldn't take
a traumatic experience to have you know
we do so many things for our bodies
thank God like look 40 years ago nobody
was going to the gym
like actually nobody so you know like
when I think about that this is what I
look like at 47 years old like
what I would have looked like if I was
born 50 years earlier like left to my
Laurels I'd be 215 that could be a mess
well I think you started you know I'm
trying to think back all the content but
you started taking your health more
seriously in your 30s yeah late 30s 38
and a half I always laugh because I was
it was on a plane where I was like just
thinking and I was like you know things
are going well like life's gonna be good
like this is the vulnerability like
I could die from a heart attack at 63.
you know I was like I'm not I know that
I'm not doing the right things and here
I am running around the world telling
people like you're doing this wrong in
business and I'm like well you want like
you know you want your business to be a
million dollars after 19 days that's why
you're failing same with me like I
didn't I was too logical to know that 19
days in the gym would fix it I just
didn't want to put in the work it
doesn't come now you know the big I
would tell you my own Journey on health
and wellness is why I have confidence in
people's journey in business
nobody
I'm nine I'm now nine years into this
journey and there's not a single morning
I wake up and want to do it not one
you know like
it's funny I've been playing some
basketball lately I played again this
morning I played yesterday and today
yesterday was a Sunday and I woke up at
5 30 in the morning to play basketball
and it's interesting because that I love
but like I logically know at 47 it's
hard to play basketball like it's after
40 it's a very dangerous sport yeah I
mean it's not even about the game it's
about like acl's like MCL like you're so
prone in basketball
um but it's um but I love it I'll wake
up at 5 30 for it whereas like go and do
like a chest day or cardi like I like
those I've kind of like it but like it
still comes so not natural so you know
yeah I I think a lot about that and I
think about business I think about
health and wellness but lately I've been
thinking more about perspective practice
like we do a lot of practice to like be
healthy eat well go to the gym we do a
lot of business coaches this I wonder if
like I always think about like what do
none of us doing right now that's gonna
be a thing in 50 years I think
perspective practice
like this maybe because you're close to
my content like I why I tell people like
go and
go and visit a retirement home
like charity work like right now today
it's easier for me back to like what you
said about time it's easier today for me
to write a check
than to go spend a day right like
like a kitchen that serves people in
need like one of the so this year I've
already done more things this year in my
personal life visiting friends that have
personal situations that require me
visiting them to check on them to check
in already more in the first 23 days of
this year than I did all of last year
wow because I decided I used to say well
I don't have time to work out [__]
and so now I'm like you know I've got to
make time to do this and so it's almost
like perspective training I'm doing it
to be gracious to provide value for
somebody I care about
but there's a subconscious part of me
that knows that there's also major
deposits being put into me
you do leave with tons of gratitude
and then you know I'm hoping to scale
that to strangers because luckily I'm
not in a situation where I have a lot of
those in my life
but you know I think I've really been
thinking a lot about that like what if
once a month 12 times a year
you go and go out of your way to be of
service with your time
because some buddy or some group of
people in need that also gives you a
real look at
you know a life that you know you're
complaining about XYZ and like there's
people who are terminally ill I you know
I've gotten a point in my career where
you know a lot of people are dming me
with like Make-a-Wish like scenarios
literally this week in my DM I'm so glad
I made the video I'm so glad I saw it
I'm so glad I made the video and the the
friends the guy who was six friend
reached out to me and said I was an
inspiration for this guy and the
gentleman passed and just like [__]
like
35 years old you know and it's just like
I just struggle worrying about money or
reputation though I care way more about
my reputation than money or like
anything
when you just know this is happening
every day and things are happening every
day yeah
that's um I saw something on Twitter
Twitter like it hit me really hard last
week or the week before there's some guy
like they said you know basically like
I'm signing off you know like I guess he
was battling with something terminal and
then no one knew about it I I didn't
even follow the guy I don't know who he
was but so I'm signing off you know has
been a great you know loving everyone
like you know and it's like because I
only have like a few days left or
something like that and I need to like
spend with my family yeah it's just like
and it bothers me it's one of those
things that like
I think a lot about like fear like you
were scared to kiss a girl or guy you
were scared to ride a bike I was
petrified of swimming I didn't start
swimming until I was nine only because
my sister started swimming at six and I
heard like my mom be like Liz she's
swimming and I like was playing knock
hockey at the pool club and literally
ran and jumped in the pool and tried to
make pretend I was swimming at the same
time as my sister like thank God for my
competitive juices but like I think
people fear a lot of things that are
mundane in real life and then like they
just seem so simple like ever being
scared to ride a bike or or kiss someone
or have sex or you know swim or ride a
bike like they become so standard
and I think a lot about that lately
first time last five years of the
reverse which is like
you can only start being appreciative or
grateful when something bad happens and
we have to find a way to change that
yeah I think I'm so happy because that's
not what's happening for me I actually
wake up on a gloomy Monday like this and
being like boom another [__] day that
nothing atrocious happened let's go I
really believe that and it gets really
in I think it's why I have such a
capacity to do so many things
it's not because I have like more energy
though I have high energy it's not that
I'm like so much more talented I have
put in the Reps and have the talent it's
that I'm just not
scared and so that doesn't drag me down
it's tough to do podcasting or scared of
it yeah and that's for me you know like
if you talk about like I look back I
think I've heard you speak about this
too you know during like teenage years
and girls and stuff yeah I look back now
like
like why was I why was I scared like why
didn't ask Marielle yeah and if I look
back in 25 30 years I'll be like it's
gonna be the same thing that's why I
focus so much on 20 30 year olds and
even 40 year olds I would say because
they have you know 13 year olds because
a tick tock I have a very young crew
they don't have context but what you
just said is everything to me like think
about the people that didn't go to the
college that they wanted to didn't ask
out the person that they want I mean I
literally have active knowledge of
friends who still are like depressed
they didn't ask somebody out 25 years
ago like it just bothers them
and like I'm like cool no time machines
you're actively doing that right now
with this you've been saying that you
want to move out of New Jersey your
whole life the [__] are you doing in New
Jersey
I love Jersey by the way like don't clip
that inappropriately but like like like
I don't want to hear from friends who
are like I want to move to a warmer
weather place I want to move to a warmer
weather place I want to move to warmer
and then equally they're spending all
their time saying I wish in high school
I'm like you're doing it like cool
you're not going back to high school and
being able to do that but right now
you've been saying for four years that
you're gonna move to a warmer weather
place not asking out Mary is the same
thing as not moving to [__] Florida
or Texas or Arizona or no [__] who's
on your mind
it's a big deal
and that is why because they do know
you can recall just you're 28 you can
recall 12 years ago like a piece of cake
and be like [__] I wish I
because people don't want rejection
yeah well it's the fear right it's just
I made fun of or like looking bad in
front of your boys and like ha ha like
it's funny I have a friend who's got an
eighth grader who asked a girl out and
it kind of went it botched but not bad
as a matter of fact I think they just
went on a date so I'm super pumped for
him
and all his boys made fun of him and he
just looked at him all and said like at
least I had the boss to ask someone out
and I was like that's it uh Nate who now
runs my Foundation who's my partner in
empathy wines
we played tennis a bunch
both summers ago and I beat him in all
six seven matches we only played one set
and in two of those matches he was up
five to two
and I came all the way back in 175.
and
for like the next two years I would Razz
up like we would have so many who's my
chief of staff so we would have all
these meetings and it would have there'd
be no segue for me to bring it up but I
just wanted to bring it up
and finally and you know I'm I'm his guy
like you know I'm the boss like I get
why he wouldn't say anything and I
finally grabbed him I was like hey
the next time I say this I want you to
look at me and say what's your handicap
because he's a scratch golfer
scratch and it was funny between me
telling you that story and telling you
about my friend's son
that's how I think about eliminating the
lack of the fear of the Judgment of your
rejection most people are actually not
scared of the girl saying no they're
scared that their boys are going to make
fun of them for the girl saying no and
like what I want the world to realize is
like when your boys do that when your
older brother does that when your mom
does that you just call them on their
like if the kids of the world knew that
when their mom or dad is [__] on
them that they could just take a step
back Dodge that punch and go directly at
something that their parents have done
horribly it would actually settle it
it would make them take more risk like
cool mom you're [__] on me but what
about when this happened for you like
you have to
you don't have to punch back nasty
you just have to push back
in context it would work for people
because that's what makes me not scared
that if and even three of you knew me my
whole life and were like what about that
time you did that like I don't
understand right it's it's also why I
don't think I'm special
right like yeah okay I'm good at making
money in business I genuinely to the
core of my self being don't think that's
a big deal it means it's just something
I do some people are just handsome some
people can throw a baseball 100 miles an
hour some people are just very gracious
guidance like everyone's got stuff
everyone's got strengths and weaknesses
and we just have to have that combo and
for you like the reason I'm going so
hard at this subject matter over this
time together is the fact that you're
really like starting to do it I'm just
trying to be like harder more yeah
that's yeah because I know I'm I'm
self-aware enough to know about myself
that's that's all I need it's just a big
kick in the ass and and if you actually
realize the big I'll tell you how you're
about to go fast if you don't beat
yourself up for the last 20 somebody
who's self-aware what they'll do is be
like
it's almost like cool you've now
acknowledged that
never think or talk about it again like
don't spend any energy on it
yeah because a lot of people like like I
love watching people make progress
who struggle to make progress and
whatever we're talking about then decide
when they've got a little taste of
things are going well how quickly
they'll let the old Behavior seep back
in
oh I'll try I'm looking at you for a
reason that's exactly what I see in you
in such a fun way like that I'm almost
like you know knowing you're in a room
I'm almost saying this for you like I
see it
and it's cool because it means you're
halfway home you did the new thing which
established this better energy that's
like foreign to begin with it's like
whoa
I might be changing evolving but it's so
cliche to then like be like yeah like
really I'm this and like this was a good
moment or for you like oh when I'm
around Gary it's like that but it's like
it's not it's like you just have to
realize this thing is actually dead but
it takes like a few minutes to go into
that full place
like like I said like last week
last week first time like you know
posting the video like putting my face
out there huge it's it's something small
for so many but for me brother you want
to hear something insane it's not you
wanna you wanna hear something funny
Jordy that's not posting their life is
much bigger than people like me
that's why that's where the cup got it
notice how that combo just went hey it
seems like a small I know it's small for
so many people but I put my face on it
no no no no
most people don't put their face on it
kind of like the iceberg you know it's
all that that's exactly what it is
because you can't see it's back to how I
talk about happiness everyone's like the
world sucks I'm like no no the negative
people are just loud right now until
positive people get louder you won't
understand the complex you won't
understand the context you won't
understand the math
I can't be such an enigma
I need more people that are positive to
Get Loud Like I Do which like what about
this good thing what about this good
thing what about this opportunity I
definitely understand all the
unfortunately you know the negativity
and media are anywhere just it's
Amplified someone spreads much faster
and louder right but but but there's
also so much more volume of it
like I'm pretty viral
like there's plenty of room for people
that sell love for virality like there's
a real path to it you know
um just got to be louder more people and
it's like those people are iconic and
I'm not even like in that conversation
but there's there's millions of me out
there they just haven't they're so
selfish in their happiness my biggest
problem is negativity wants to be viral
people want to drag people down to their
unhappiness
I believe when I analyze when I talk to
myself about like what are you doing
what I'm interested in is my generosity
of the positivity I notice all the
people I've come across in life that are
like me just keep to themselves and
enjoy their happiness I'm willing to
take the [__] arrows and all the [__]
that comes along with putting yourself
out there for the purpose of positivity
and I think a lot more happy people have
to take on that challenge yeah that's um
I've thought of it like that that's
that's it's almost like you're doing
like a noble because I I the reason I'm
identified is because I can see myself a
little bit like that you know like I can
see like I'm kind of like one of those
people you know that well it's probably
What attracted you to me
right like you can see it everything
you're saying like you know it's why
you're pushing yourself yeah
it's why you're pushing yourself it's
cool if that's your engine then you're
really gonna have a good time at this
like for me
I think a lot of people do what I do for
a living for the money and the fame
for me it's for the satisfaction that I
didn't live life
selfishly
that there's great joy for me I really
enjoy it
I've had to find my own balance in that
because what it for me as someone who
loves to give what I do is when I don't
communicate with the people I'm giving
love to well it leads to resentment I've
had to be on a reverse journey of most
people
um but
a big opportunity
that's a really Noble Mission it's
you'll always have energy for it when
you do it for the money and the fame you
will run out of gas when you do it
because you feel like you want to leave
a positive deposit you'll do it to the
end
yeah again just going back to you know
80 90. that's what that's what I've been
thinking about lately is like you know
what do I
that seems to be the only you know
that's something kind of to get kick me
into gears like well death you're gonna
die
so when you do that you want to be able
to look back and say like like what's
what did you leave like the world with
right what what was your Lasting
Impression did you just do nothing or
hermit or negative or did you leave it
you know with a bunch of positive right
positive neutral or negative yeah yeah
right now I'm I'm neutral but you're not
because you've already started the
positive Journey which is huge and you
know I was talking to Dustin earlier
like
once you know like it once they get
going like I can I can feel it like the
momentum the the game plan the strategy
I mean the individual creatives yeah
those always need tweaking but the
strategy you know I just tell people
just follow me what you say it's just so
simple just the volume the volume volume
is going to dominate right
um I do obsess a little bit over the
quality but I do too
but I think quality is subjective
yeah quality subjective what Dustin
thinks is a quality BMX video is not
something I even want to consider
watching let alone beginning to judge if
it is if if you're not interested in
buying things at garage sales and
selling them on eBay trash talk is very
low quality meanwhile thousands of
people have emailed me that it's the
thing that got them to get clearing debt
or creating a nice family vacation that
is massive value when the two themes of
Trash Talk are I clear debt oh my God I
can't believe it by buying t-shirts and
trinkets and mugs at garage sales or my
family had a nicer vacation this both of
those are profound the top 15 things in
life
but if you're not interested like and so
like the reason I always love volume is
the numbers is not a debate if you post
19 times a week versus four you've
posted 19 times versus four this concept
of like well my four are quality and
you're 19 aren't Gary that's insecurity
and ego debating with me not truth if
that like we don't have a universal
quality guide like there's too much
interest and Intrigue and too many
nuances you know and so
somebody said to me that I know pretty
well that's of my age he's like Gary I
gotta really cut Social out it's just
like a complete waste for me and I'm
like cool brother but I know you and
what you were doing in that same time
was just watching TV
which is fine not negative or or
positive you know one should one could
argue that you have way more control
over your algorithm for example one
thing I'm fascinated I have to make a
piece of content about this
I've completely changed my algorithms I
just decided that I wanted to see a lot
more business news because I'm making a
lot more green screens right and so like
instead of spending time
this is so funny you know people like
social media is a waste of time I just
made social media a time efficient
machine for me I and the team look for
headlines for me to make content to talk
about
uh when you know teams sharing stuff
what they think is good and a lot of
times like it works and a lot of times
it doesn't work like I'm like I'm not
into that I want to talk about that so
I've put it on myself so it a lot of
like a lot in the last 30 40 days 60
days I'm like spending 10 15 minutes
looking for headlines and like news or
that's a lot of time in my life right
now where I'm at and then I realize like
wait a minute
I'm just gonna follow like 50 accounts
on Instagram and Tick Tock that I looked
at their accounts and I'm like this is
exactly the kind of imagery that I would
do a headline against and let me just
follow and like now it's coming to me
I changed my entire algorithm everyone's
at the algor and the other way the
algorithm just wants you to stay on so
if you show the algorithm that you want
so like literally the number one hack
for everyone in the world that claims
they're unhappy with social is to go to
the search bar on Tick Tock or Instagram
and search the subject matters they
think are bringing them value follow 50
accounts like their content the first
time they show up and your whole algo
will change
in fact when you keep dwelling on that
negatives they'll keep consuming of
course it's just going to keep you worse
like if you're gonna rub her neck to car
crashes you're gonna be upset
if that's all you do I I think there's a
profound like this goes back to
self-accountability when I was growing
up it was all bashing TV kids are
watching too much TV kids are watching
too much to me kids are watching too
much to me
it's just this it's the way the World
Turns
yeah it's been really interesting
changing by algo it's been good very
efficient I was a lot I saw you posted
something too about uh sometimes I
thought it was funny sometimes you
really tried to mess it up you know
you'll search like pickles or stuff like
that yeah just to like learn yeah like
it's kind of like I think social media
is like a wild horse
you know either you're gonna figure out
how to tame it and work for you or it's
going to run wild to like be a bull in a
china shop like
it's bull fighting either you can tame
it or you are gonna get pierced by it
and I think that's on the person because
every person can delete the app
I hate this thing delete yeah
discipline
let's go inside it's really interesting
but like definitely for learning
it's I'm really actually like feel like
I'm more on top of [__] right now
because of the way my feet is going
in terms of I'm just seeing a lot of
like like I'm by Nature I'm like a very
good entrepreneur but like I'm not a
macro or a micro Economist right right
so like I'm not like like with what's
going on with the recession or potential
recession or whatever people want to
call it the global economy like I'm
enjoying the headlines I'm getting and
then what I'm doing is you know social
is very fast so I'll see a headline of
like this is you know the US May default
I'm like what is that like I'm not edu
like I know the title but then like
because I saw it in the feed and because
it was sat Sunday afternoon instead of
like sitting down and reading a book you
know it's amazing reading a book on a
Sunday afternoon with like a nice cup of
tea or glass of wine that seems like
very classy being on your phone seems
like right but like for me it was like
boom to then Google to then like like
and like I was getting it I'm taking I'm
like in school
but it's on my phone well I know it's
it's people are judging the medium
instead of what you're doing inside of
it you know
I started I was
really like my you know if you want to
look at the judge a page five success on
views you know on Tick Tock of course I
was really going well there was like
some crypto stuff I was covering like uh
you know kind of educated people what's
going on broke my leg kind of felt you
know the pain loss is so long and I fell
out of like you know you got out of
rhythm the fear came back in and stuff
like that why does break down the fear
for me for five seconds fun I I think
it's just just
what people think
yeah and was that a cultural thing was
that a family thing like I think for
example I'll give an example I'm
incredibly private
people are confused by that when I say
it but like I don't share my personal
life I never have
but I think that's a family history
thing because my family grew up in the
Soviet Union and the only way you
survived in the Soviet Union was by
privacy yeah everyone was scared yeah if
somebody tattle-tailed on you and the
government would put you in jail or
worse so for Generations my family's
like you know you don't talk about
anything so that's interesting so you're
saying that those that mindset you
developed there that was more from how
you were raised instead of I always
thought that was just you were
Sheltering your family like your
personal stuff from the public you know
or maybe a bit of both there I think it
was naturally in me to be private and
then I think I quickly understood that I
had it like I remember vividly being a
year into Wine Library TV and being like
Oh like
like a lot of people may know who I am
one day like knowing that there was more
and so I feel like I consciously knew
that it would be a good thing to protect
that but that wasn't SEC that was the
number two thing the number one thing
was my whole life I've been private it's
my natural state I don't want to you
know it's very funny it's very
empathetic by the way one of the reasons
I'm private is that I don't want other
people to have to worry about me
my biggest weakness up to this point in
my life is the inability to be
vulnerable
I just don't want to put baggage on
people
have their own it's also my greatest
gift in a world-free home most people
are struggling with [__] and really the
things that I struggle with are like
like it's a it's just shocking to me how
little ability I have to dwell on my
biggest concerns
the thought that anything lasts a day is
profound
I was listening to a podcast with you
and Stephen Bartlett yes
he said it was very very rare for it to
make it to the next morning so yeah it's
very I mean no oh like business stuff is
ever like the things that go are like
the people you care about and things of
that nature but even those by standards
of like knowing people
so that's another reason why I struggle
with like you know going there it's like
uh
there's really not you know that really
my mom is like really the person that
I'm wired like but like it's your mom I
don't like anything I'm worried about is
she's gonna worry about it 10 times more
so that's like not that's why therapy is
so profoundly important for people like
you know it just it's an outlet and like
a lot of people use their friends but
then they're dragging their friends down
you know like if you're inherently like
if you're inherently struggling
you you need to get that poison out
but you know people get it right like if
they're doing that with their best
friend they'll watch their relationship
with their best friend deteriorate based
on that because no human no matter how
[__] empathetic they are is really
like going to be drawn to you know rain
and frowns 24 like right and so like
I've been thinking and then I think a
lot about the cost of therapy so that's
been a huge one for me lately I'm like
okay cool Gary's on a podcast and be
like go do therapy why who the [__] has
like I don't know you know 100 I don't
know what the pricing is I'm sure you
can I'm sure there's online things but
like there's just like
just think about like new alternatives
to get it like so one thing I've been
very fascinated by back to like where
you went like I've been thinking a lot
about this concept of
I said it earlier what are people going
to do in 50 years that nobody does now
one of my hot takes is
one of the things humans are going to do
is go into the woods
and just like yell it out I'm not
kidding I'm like really hot on this you
know like weird Trend start like you
know like diets or like fads or like
like you know everything from
veganism to carnivore to uh CrossFit
like I really think yelling and getting
[__] out is really good
breathing the breathing thing is really
interesting to me
like
one of my favorite things is on my text
thing to just send a text and be like
just take a deep deep breath and
physically smile I am fascinated by what
people sent me back
and I know this to be true because I do
it I've been doing it more like I've
been like trying to figure out
that more and more for me
I'm very interested in it
kind of taking a pause in this well just
like it seemed like again when you get
Fs in science and you haven't done the
homework like I haven't I'm intrigued by
all the headlines and the conversation
and popular culture about the values of
breathing and like seemingly without any
education on this I feel intuitive that
it's right because I'm on the receiving
end of it
um
I just think a lot of people just
they're just a little like again it's
how my brain works it's how Trash Talk
started hey you should invest in
companies like I did cool who's got
twenty five thousand dollars to [__]
throw like you know like I was I was
risk tolerant to do that it's not like I
even had that much because at the time I
had so little money but I was just like
okay with like that risk
most people aren't so led to like okay
fine I'll teach you how to buy things
for a dollar and sell for 13 and same
with this like I really want people to
start doing more therapy
oh [__] A lot of people who listen can't
for a million different reasons
financially
taboo and their fam like they can't get
through the taboo
um okay well maybe breathing is it
and like breathing is [__] free
simple it's [__] simple like like
I'll do it right now and feel like I
actually feel something like
it's really fascinating to me like I
genuinely feel less pressure like I
don't know it really calms this I mean I
know there's incredible science behind
this truth but like I just want that to
be as real as working out
I believe more people wake up and do an
hour workout a day than people take a
deep breath with purpose to reset their
anxiety level I believe that could be
true I could be wrong but that's my gut
feeling on what's going on and like
that's the stuff that excites me and I
just think like in New York City so much
stress like driving an hour to Jersey or
Long Island or somewhere close going
into the woods and just like saying all
the things you wish you could say to
like people no different than therapy I
have this weird feeling is going to
become a thing because I think people
want to be outside more this that like
those are things whether that becomes a
thing or not though that's how I like to
create ideas in terms of Technology
people say old technology is bad
I just really optimistic on technology
like not not just obviously what it's
doing stuff but you're talking about
like artificial intelligence and all
that yeah like yeah that's a good one
that's right everyone's like this is
going to ruin everything I'm like that's
what you said about tractors that's what
you said about the TV it's not the
ability to improve everyone's lives so
much so much you can focus the amount of
humans that can be able to focus on
something more productive not to mention
what nobody's talking about like with
chat GPT right
this is so bad I'm like it's teaching
critical thinking you have to still tell
the machine it's like search engines
like when I first started using search
engines I was bad at it
I was like it was like yeah it's like no
assistance right it was like wine and
then later it's like you know where are
the one you know
same with this like right now with all
the AI people are like write a paper for
me about this later it's gonna be like
okay write this paper about Lord of the
Flies in the voice of a saint from the
1500s with a cynical point of view to
Birdie's situation like it becomes
critical thinking
for me as someone who's creative and
likes to see different angles it's going
to be profound
I knew simple editing but I I don't mind
doing it but I don't like in the moment
I feel like I think I'm thinking like oh
I could be spending this time doing you
know coming up with content or something
right
I was talking about a few tools out
there you know obviously people heard
like China Tea and Dolly some of these
images but I think it's been really cool
you know I think video like I'm really
big I think video is like the most liked
media uh comedian for the big concern I
have is with deep fake yeah
I believe that video proof has been the
judge and jury of our society for the
last 70 years yeah and yeah I'm really
worried about that could you imagine the
bad guys being able to be like that
video is not true I saw one and like it
took me I think it was an Elon uh yeah
something uh it took me like a few it
took me like probably 10 seconds at
least to like like and I only could tell
it wasn't really because the the face
and the The Voice weren't lining up it
was just the cut like what he was saying
I was like I don't know it didn't make
sense but it's it's good it's scary good
oh no I I fully believe that in 46
months there'll be unlimited videos of
me saying things that I'd never said
to your point of video testimonials I
would I would argue that it is the most
challenging debate I have in my mind
that almost everything up into this
point in my life I've had like shocking
Clarity and on like the whatever and it
became true that this one is hard for me
that I think there has to be a counter
technology yeah I'm trying to think like
like a badge like something like you
know you have like I always sometimes
simplify it may excuse me it may lead to
a shocking amount of live video I've
been thinking a lot about like what if
this goes so awry that nobody believes
it am I gonna be like live all the time
be like like proving that I'm live and
like you know it's wild but overall like
optimistic on on technology and then its
ability to improve our all of our lives
I think I mean that that's just been
proven
like you don't want penicillin you don't
want x-ray machines you don't want like
just like the conversation's so cliche
human fear and the best is one I I see
older Generations my grandparents my
grandparents had an iPad before I I even
got one interesting and
it's you know not them in particular but
you know you hear some some of the old
Generations you know technology is bad
yeah and have this when I was growing up
we're all better for it but
you know what the amount of times I see
people on their phones just playing like
older generation playing a game or on
Facebook or something and it's it's you
can tell like they're doing it for
they're choosing to spend their time on
on that like it's it's obviously giving
them value it's improving their life
yeah so yeah I mean do you know how many
people how many 89 year olds are lonely
in retirement homes that have gotten
tremendous value of using the internet
and social media
you know any families like would go and
visit their great grandparent in the
home once a year
and now they're able to keep up with
them through Face Time and social and
texting I mean these are profound
Technologies yeah
profound